Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vous et activer la petite cloche !
Bonjour à toutes les Épicurieuses et tous lesÉpicurieux
aujourd'hui c'est mercredi,
comme chaque mercredi je réponds aux questions
quevous m'avez posées avec #DisJamy.
Une question de david_lprx, posée surInsta,
"Dis Jamy, Épicurieux par rapport
à Epicure et aux épicuriens ?"
Alors Épicurieux est un mot qui a été inventé
c'est ce qu'on appelle un néologisme.
Il est construit à partir
de l'adjectif curieux et de l'adjectif épicurien.
Un épicurien c'est le nomque l'on donne
à une personne qui aime la vie.
Qui aime la bonne table.
Qui aime réunir sesamis autour d'un bon repas,
échanger avec eux.
On dit que c'est un épicurien.
Alors Épicurieux, ehbien,
c'est justement le nom d'une communauté :
la vôtre,
la nôtre.
La communauté de toutes celles
et ceux qui aiment se poser des questions
aiment apprendre et comprendre.
C'est exactement ceque je suis en train
de faire là, en ce moment.
Je réponds à vos questions
et j'espère quevous y prenez plaisir.
Une question de Louis_Kypp,
"Dis Jamy, vas-tu aller dans d'autres pays
pour nous faire découvrir
des choses uniques à ce pays ?"
Oui !
Vous pouvez compter sur moi dèsque
je vais me retrouver à l'étranger dans une autre région
ou même
à quelques kilomètresde chez moi dès que
je vais voir quelque chose d'étonnant, de curieux
qui mérite qu'on le
raconte et bien je le partagerai avec vous.
C'est pour cette raison que j'ai créé Épicurieux.
Unequestion de vic.beyer,
"Dis Jamy, comment va ton chat?"
Eh bien Nitro se porte très bien.
Je vous l'aurais bien présentée
mais comme d'habitude elle se cache.
Elle est probablement,en ce moment,
dans un fauteuil en train de faire la sieste
ou peut-être dans le jardin
en train des'amuser.
Une question d'antoine.leb,
"Dis Jamy, quel sera le rythme de publication
de ces petitssnacks de culture que tu nous offres ?"
J'adore cette expression
"petit snack de culture".
Eh bien le rythme sera le suivant :
"Chez Jamy", un samedi sur deux
comme c'est le cas depuis le début.
Ensuite tous les lundis, "Sur la planche"
où je vous raconte l'histoire d'un aliment,
l'origine de son nom ouson origine géographique.
Le mercredi, "Dis Jamy",
ce que je suis en train de faire en ce moment.
Et le jeudi, "Pourquoi On Dit ?"
donc un programme qui est destiné à expliquer
l'origine desexpressions de la langue française
Et puis autour de tout cela, eh bien,
beaucoup d'autrespetits programmes...
Bref !
Restez attentifs, il y en aura
pour tous les goûts et tous les jours.
Et ce sera parfaitement digeste
comme l'impose un petit snack de culture
comme vous le dites sibien.
Une question d'azo_algue,
"Dis Jamy, à quand une nuit de la culture avec Étoiles ?"
Eh bienÉtoiles m'a contactée sur Twitter,
nous sommes en train de discuter en privé.
Peut-être réussironsnous à faire quelque chose ensemble.
En tout cas, j'adorerais faire une nuit de la culture
avec unestar de Twitch.
Une question de Mario Sunshine sur Youtube,
"Dis Jamy, pourquoi avoir changé ta chaîne
enrajoutant Épicurieux ?"
Alors d'abord la chaîne n'a pas changé,
j'ai voulu ajouter ce mot "épicurieux"
et appeler cette chaîne Épicurieux
parce-que ce terme représente davantage
ce qu'est cettechaîne.
C'est à dire une communauté de personnes curieuses
et une communauté de personnes
quiaiment apprendre et comprendre
tout simplement.